[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to an opening
video which is actually the second
opening video i've ever done on my
channel
uh the first one being a video on uh the
stafford gamut i'm refuting the stafford
uh now
i've wanted to do
more opening videos on my channel and
i've talked about that on stream
what kept me from doing that is just a
little bit of nervousness i have tons of
analysis that i want to share but i'm
not very experienced at making opening
videos so you know for a while it's
going to be you know some trial and
error and uh you know i ask for your
patience but i figured if i don't
actually start sharing my analysis and
doing opening videos well uh then i'm
never gonna do them so without further
ado uh this is another entry in
naredinsky's opening lab and in
particular uh i am very passionate about
teaching y'all to refute gambits and
refute tricky lines
uh and you know not to get discouraged
from mainstream openings because of the
presence of these lines and today's
topic is going to be the
uh notorious and incredibly dreaded
traxler counter attack now what is the
track sir well uh the tracks are happens
in the italian and the fried liver
variation
and uh it's a very very commonly
recommended trick opening it's actually
very dangerous and it's not just a
gimmick it's a very serious opening
system that needs a lot of attention and
in this video i'm going to show you
exactly what you need to know in order
to successfully defeat the traxler i'm
going to teach you a
a relatively rare line and show you
everything that you need to know about
it so
uh without further ado what is the track
sir so in the italian bishop c4
knight f6 white plays naichi phi which
is the fried liver attack that is one of
the most common
opening variations in chess among really
among all levels but particularly
beginner and intermediate and here uh
you might uh be familiar if you're a
fried liver player that d5 is black's
main move intercepting the bishop and
then after e takes d5
black is not supposed to take this pawn
black is supposed to play knight a5 and
this leads to a very theoretical line
uh but the traxler in in this position
is to play the move bishop c5 this is
the move that bears the name traxler
counter attack and
at first blush it may seem like a
totally absurd move it just leaves the
pawn on f7 hanging and that's exactly
the point most people who face the
tracks are for the first time think that
it's a blunder they think that the
opponent was not expecting knight g5 it
might be a bad pre-move
and uh they immediately grab the pawn on
f7 and that's where it hits them black
responds with bishop takes f2 check you
might have seen this in one of levi's
videos or eric rosen's excellent videos
and this is a legitimate bishop
sacrifice that leads to wild
complications if you take this bishop
and after knight takes e4 check all of a
sudden the king lands in a lot of
trouble and one of the famous trick
lines here goes king e3 uh looks like
black's pieces are all hanging but after
queen h4 black has all these made
threats uh because he's got a lot of
pieces in the attack and if white just
keeps grabbing material where he well
he's going to get mated queen f4 check
then queen f2 check knight c5 and queen
t4 is one of the
more famous mating sequences in the
traxler but that's not important all of
the complications after knight takes f7
are wild
and uh definitely not in the spirit of
my opening recommendations i i don't
want to recommend anything that requires
crazy memorization and as far as i know
white is not even supposed to be better
in this line of the tracks there now a
lot of
uh sources from the white side tend to
recommend the other capture bishop takes
f7 check and then after king e7 just
dropping the bishop all the way back
either to c4 or to b3 now this is a very
good recommendation and it's also the
computer's top line but i don't believe
that it's very practical and the reason
i say that is because after rook f8
which is the commonly recommended
response black has a lot of practical
compensation in return for the pawn now
what does the word practical mean well
it means that although white is
objectively better if he plays all the
right moves it's actually very scary and
it's not a very good idea in my opinion
to have this position with the white
pieces in a blitz game as you can see
black has a lot of pressure on the f2
pawn
and if white proceeds
kind of you know without thinking after
something like knight c3 what often
happens well black plays h6 and chases
the knight away then black plays d6 and
if white plays nonchalantly all of a
sudden
after something like bishop g4 black has
quite a bit of pressure on white's
position you know white castles there's
knight d4 and you can kind of see how
this can get nasty black's king yes it's
on e7 but it's actually pretty safe from
any immediate
checks so after a lot of contemplation i
decided not to recommend
this uh line with bishop takes f7 and
instead to search for something more
rare and i was able to find it in the
move
that i would like to recommend to
everyone is d4 now by popularity this is
you know third by a country mile knight
f7 and bishop f7
are not just more popular but d4 is
virtually unheard of at at the top level
uh the chess.com opening sport
essentially has 20 games with it and uh
to levy rosman's great credit he does
mention it in his traxxar video so it's
not like this move is totally unknown
um but it is
very likely to catch your opponent
totally off guard and that is the first
reason that i'm recommending it if black
does not find the only response d5
counter-attacking white bishop far from
an intuitive move then black is going to
land immediately in a completely lost
position
now you might be looking at this
movement saying okay i get that it opens
up the bishop but what exactly is the
point if black just plays bishop takes
d4 well here's the genius of that move
now white plays knight f7 but daniel
didn't you just say that bishop takes f2
check leads to complete and utter
pandemonium well it does without the
move d4 well what's the difference let's
follow one of the key lines king takes
f2
i take c4 checking drops back to g1 this
is a key move
now we're following uh the main line of
the traxxar with or without d4 black
plays queen h4
uh if instead
if instead black plays queen f6
threatening made on f2 then white can
simply respond queen e2 and the game is
over the knight is hanging and the rook
is saying a black's attack completely
evaporates so queen h4 is the move
uh white responds with g3 and of course
as you might imagine black plays knight
takes you through very much in the
spirit of the traxler
and uh here white actually doesn't take
the knight on g3
but rather grabs the rook on h8
okay this position might look very crazy
but uh in reality white's just got a
bunch of extra pieces and the only way
the black has to continue the attack
is to get this other knight into the
game with knight d4
um if black takes the bishop on c4 then
white just takes the knight if black
takes the rook on h1 well the simplest
is to play queen d5 and just look at
this position carefully white is up a
piece and white is threatening all of
these checkmates against the black king
queenie one check is completely
innocuous and in this position it's
important to note that there is no
checkmate because the bishop controls f1
the king easily escapes the checks and
white wins
so uh really the only way that black can
play here is to play knight t4
let's consider this exact position
but without d4 thrown in how does that
actually impact
this position that's going to help us
understand why d4 is such a great move
so knight f7 bishop f2 now we're looking
at this from the point of view of the
main line uh without the immediate
knight takes f7 okay so g3 knight takes
g3 knight takes h8 knight d4
okay so white plays h takes g3 queen
takes g3 check after king f1 it's a draw
by perpetual check this is one of the
main lines black as queen f4 check and
it turns out that the white king cannot
escape perpetual if you go king e1 uh
there's actually several ways to do it
the simplest being queen g3 and if you
go king g2 then the queen steps back to
g5 and you can convince yourself but
there is no way to escape perpetual if
you try to run to h3 you're actually
going to lose the game after black
activates the bishop
okay so
what exactly is the point of d4 then
well let's transition back
uh to the position this exact same
position
with the inclusion of the move d4 and i
think if you have a key and i toward the
position you can already get where i'm
going with this look at this bishop on
c1 what is this bishop going to be doing
if the pawn on d2
is no longer there well let's go back to
that d4
go let's go through that line again
because if you play d4 i can guarantee
you that you will face this a lot
because people are going to be following
what they think
is the main line of the track so knight
g3 knight h894
hg3 queen g3 king f1 and here they are
going to be awakened with a cold shower
the fact that queen f4 check is no
longer possible because the bishop is
controlling that square this is the
whole point of playing d4 and black can
simply resign the game he's down a rook
and a piece
and if he tries to go d5 and activate
the bishop via h3
rather than greedily taking the pawn
white throws in queen h5 check
after g6 the cutest move is actually
knight takes g6 remember that any queen
trait ends the game immediately and
after h takes g6 queen h8 check followed
by rook h7 check is absolutely and
totally crushing light is upper rook and
also mating
so this is the point of d4
and this is its first appealing factor
the fact that if black takes on d4 with
the bishop this line is totally forcing
and it ends in a loss for black there's
just nothing
that black can do about it
so bishop takes d4 loses well you might
ask what about knight takes d4 well
knight txt4 loses in a similar way it
actually covers
uh the bishop's access to f2 and after
knight f7 black doesn't have the main
traxler idea and he simply has to give
away the rook on h8 there's one subtlety
here that i should mention
if knight takes c4 happens the simplest
win is queen h5 check g6 and again
knight takes g6 this is a by the way a
theme in this line this queen h5 and
knight takes g6 stuff here the point is
that you recapture and then you take the
knight on e4 you have an extra rook
uh so a couple of people have played d5
in this position
uh hoping to get this bishop into g4
with tempo and you have to remember that
you've won an entire rook so
it's not really about winning as much
material as you can but rather about
consolidating getting your pieces out as
quickly as you can and so bishop e2 here
is the most careful move and although
the knights look pretty intimidating
here you can already guess once again
bishop h5 check the same exact idea g6
and boom knight takes g6
then you take on g6 and this is one of
many different
winning ideas king f8 bishop h6 jack and
if king d8 and after bishop takes c4 d
takes e4 even without the next move
white would be winning even if you just
castle here you're up in exchange but of
course the simplest is to go c3 and pick
up the knight on d4 which is now pinned
uh so
this is uh also kind of losing on the
spot
and finally e takes d4
uh well this is even worse knight takes
f7 queen e7 and after knight h8 black
literally just has one check and you can
play queen e2 here and force the queen
trade you can even play king f1 that's
the computer recommendation and nothing
wrong with keeping the king on f1 it's
perfectly safe there and black has
absolutely nothing to show for the rooks
so all three recaptures lose the game
and so black has to know the move d5
counter attacking white's bishop but
that is far from all
what does white do in this
crazy looking position well the best
move is bishop takes d5 which once again
poses black with a pretty unenviable
ultimatum okay so
when i look at this position you know
the most tempting move to me
looks like it's knight takes d5
but this move leads to a nearly lost
endgame now we all of a sudden take the
bishop
okay the bishop disappears now the
knight is hanging remember that black is
now down a pawn
knight db4 is what almost everybody has
played trying to make contact with the
c2 pawn
but that doesn't do anything white plays
a3 and if black trades queens then the
king takes the queen's place and defends
the c2 pawn the knight has nothing
better than to return to a6 and now
after bishop b3 white solidifies the
pawn wright's next move is going to be
pawn b2 to b4 and on top of being up a
pawn uh look at how terribly these
knights are placed this is just a bad
endgame and also remember something i
forgot to mention at the beginning that
you know when you get a traxler player
into a very bad end game that is
literally the worst of
all worlds for that trackster player i
mean you want to get gambit players into
situations where they're just not
comfortable with the type of position
they have but apart from that white is
also essentially winning here so
the move knight takes e5 also
essentially loses the game after d c and
white is forcing an end game where he's
upon up
uh okay so that doesn't work the
absolute only move is actually knight
takes d4 which once again to me seems
quite quite a bit counterintuitive
bishop takes d4
is completely ineffective now because of
knight takes f7 and the quantico traxler
idea is complete bug
uh king takes f2 black can actually play
uh knight takes e4 check hoping for
bishop takes e4 queen h4 check and here
the simplest way to victory is just to
drop the king back to e1
looks like quinn h4 check g3 knight
takes g3 is dangerous but in comes the
bishop bishop g5 forcing the queen off
of h4 and once the queen moves away from
h1 the simplest is to take the knight on
g3 and white emerges
to pull minor pieces up so
this is
simply losing on the spot but notice in
how many different lines black
essentially loses the game with with no
chances to complicate things so he has
to follow this incredibly narrow line
knight takes d4
and the point of this is that if we take
on f7 with the knight now
then this leads to a very unclear
position black does indeed sacrifice the
rook but he gets his bishop to g4 really
quickly and you can see how impressive
uh black's development here is so
this is also a viable line for white but
not what i'm recommending so rather than
taking on f7 of the night we take a page
out of what most people recommend we
take enough seven of the bishop
the king essentially has to step up to
e7 if the king
uh walks to the side then this is just
an inferior version
of the position that we're going to be
analyzing the king on f8 is terrible
because it's blocking the rook and white
is still threatening knight f7 so
really it only makes sense to analyze
king e7
and now we quietly step aside
uh back to c4 back to where we came from
we've gotten the king onto a vulnerable
square we're threatening knight f7 and
uh it turns out that if we make a couple
more careful moves then black's uh
initiative fizzles out completely and
this is actually quite easy to remember
so
what is white's idea here how are we
going to continue well if it were white
to move then the most probable move here
is c3
uh just hitting the knight on d4 forcing
it back and the knight on d4 is
currently black's only good piece so in
order to try to continue conducting the
initiative black has to make some sort
of a move with tempo now you might ask
well what about bishop g4 well bishop g4
is completely innocuous we just play f3
somewhere ben feingold is cringing but
f3 is very good in this position i
assure you bishop h5 is forced now we
play c3 get out of there
we force the knight back to c6 and the
simplest is actually not to trade queens
but instead to move the queen aside to
e2
now you're threatening this devastating
night jump to e6
and if you're worried about not being
able to castle well if you don't get to
play knight d6 you can play bishop e3
force the bishop trade castle short when
you're up a full healthy pawn and black
is left with this really really bad king
on e7 so bishop g4
common move but not dangerous
uh in a similar fashion rook f8 which is
of course the recommended move uh
against the original bishop takes f7
check variation does absolutely nothing
here you just play c3 and we are groovin
96 is what i saw in the database and
here the simplest is just to initiate a
bunch of trades bishop takes c6 then
knight takes c6 and if black ever takes
on d1 then you take back can you king
take c6 f3 very important move don't be
afraid to play f3 in this line you are
creating a pawn chain the knight on f6
uh it's its uh influence is totally
limited and the king has a very nice
window on c2 then you're going to
complete your development and again
you're just going to be a full uh
uncompensated pawn up in the end game
which is really as good as it gets out
of the opening
so we looked at rook f8 we looked at
bishop g4
the only serious move for black here and
i even looked at queen e8 once again you
basically play c3 against anything that
isn't the move b5 or bishop g4 and after
c3 here knight c6 one funny line you can
play b4 and if black drops the bishop
back just to show you how vulnerable
black's king is b5 knight a5 bishop a3
check this is literally checkmate c5 on
passant checkmate well i guess it's not
technically checkmate but you get the
point uh so
this stuff is just really really bad for
black and he has to know the move b5
another crazy move the black has to know
and now white just drops the bishop back
to d3 no problemo no problem at all
and although it may seem like black has
a lot of activity remember that with the
idea of going c3 we are eventually going
to smoke the knight out of d4 and once
we do that black is just not left with
very much activity at all
so i looked at a couple of moves in this
position let's delve into them as
examples if h6 then we just drop the
knight back to f3 and the one very
important thing to remember is that in
this position you bring your other
knight out to d2 you solidify the knight
on f3 again i know that it may seem like
black has a lot of activity here but
that is just a complete illusion let's
say black plays a cafe while you just
play h3
then you can simply castle and in this
position you can definitely play the
move c3 but the drawback of this move
is that after takes takes rook d8 that
bishop on d3 is just a little bit flimsy
it's it's a little undefended so the
move c3 uh shouldn't always be played in
these positions and the simplest is to
drop the bishop back to e2 unpinning the
queen
threatening to take the knight on d4
and essentially forcing black to trade
after which black's initiative is
totally over white's initiative on the
other hand is just beginning look at
that king you're going to play the move
pawn to a4 in order to try to get this
c4 square open for your queen or for
your knight and because the knights are
connected to each other there is
absolutely nothing to fear on the king
side
and if black tries queen g6 then he just
drops the pawn on b5 case in point the
king is totally totally safe here so the
move h6 in this position is met with the
simple knight f3 now you might ask well
what about the move rockefe well to make
it easy for you you can still drop your
knight back to f3 offering a night trade
and very importantly if flack takes on
f3 with the knight you don't take with
the queen that walks right into the
x-ray no no no you take with a pawn
and the point here is that you don't
actually need to castle short you can go
rook g1
then queenie two
and you're actually going to castle
queen side you're going to play bishop
b3 knight d2 and then you're going to
castle queenside or you're going to
leave your king in the center where it's
perfectly safe i mean look at how many
pawns you have
the bishop can also come out to g5 and
the bottom line here and i know this is
a lot of variations but the bottom line
is that white is up upon black has no
clear-cut way to get anything resembling
an attack against the king
um and white has many different systems
of development and this is already
predicated on the fact that black has
found
you know 10 computer moves in a row so
not the worst bet i should say so c6
knight c3 is one example you're going to
get this bishop out you're going to
castle and you're going to be
much better so
this is rook f8
and my main line is queen e8 that's
probably black's best move and here you
just play knight d2
and if black tries to sneak up to g6
this is really the only line that you
should remember here you counter attack
black's knight with the move c3
and after queen takes g5 if if the
knight moves away then you just develop
defend the other knight with knight df3
and after h6 you can just snag the pawn
on b5 counter-attacking the knight on c6
black's position collapses
and if black plays queen takes g5 then
after cd queen takes g2 you get your
queen out to f3 this forces the queen
trade because the bishop is hanging so
takes takes e takes d4
and the funny thing here is that
currently black is up a pawn and yet
black is in huge huge trouble after rook
g1 look at how many things are hanging
g7 is hanging the king is still really
weak the bishop is undefended all of
black's pawns are weak and after g6 the
simplest is rook g5 skewering the bishop
to the pawn
and here yeah you can absolutely recover
the pawn
with the rook you can play rook takes p5
and you are better but there's another
very interesting try which is to go
rookie five check after king f7 just to
get onto the offensive with knight g5
check and uh king f8 you could pick up
the pawn on b5
with uh with interest i mean you've got
an amazing position in the end game the
knights coming to e6 and the computer
evaluates this as about plus one so this
is also the top computer line i'm not
just you know giving you some gimmicky
way to get into the end game
um so but this is unlikely to happen
just remember that if in this position
black has found all these moves and then
he goes queen e8 uh and then after
knight d2 goes queen g6 you counter
attack black snite with c3
and the last thing i'll say here i
didn't really analyze this move but
black could try bishop g4 in this
position and here white could play
either f3 but even better is to just
play knight f3 and again this is so very
important in the event of a trade you
shouldn't worry that you have a bad pawn
structure because okay after something
like queen d7 you can just go c3 and
chase the knight away once the knight
moves you go queen e2 and we're totally
chilling here bishop e3 knight d2 all of
this is happening
and uh
white's in white's in phenomenal shape
so my guess is that if somebody has
succeeded in reaching this position
and actually let me make a small
correction here
let me make a small correction here
after bishop g4
uh it's probably even a better idea to
play f3 as i said and if if black plays
bishop h5 i'm just checking my analysis
here then yeah then white just plays c3
white just plays c3 gets the knight off
of the off of the d4 square
and after something like 96
i mean here you take and go queen b3
check and then you can just pick up
another pawn no compensation and look at
how safe this king anyone is it's just
completely unassailable there are no
squares around it that can be attacked
so
this is
actually the best line so playoff three
in the event of bishop g4 and again i
remind you that bishop g4 here you still
play f3 so you do literally the exact
same thing whether or not black plays
the move b5 the inclusion of b5 bishop
d3 happens and this essentially
concludes my presentation of the d4
traxler the most theoretical line by far
the only thing you really have to know
by heart well you have to remember to
play bishop takes d5 if black plays c5
so a couple of key points first of all
remember why d4 is even played and the
reason it's played is so that the bishop
on c1 controls the f4 square and that is
important in this line where after queen
h4 g3 knight g3 knight h8 i'm going
really fast down this line the bishop on
c1 controls that f4 and there is no
longer perpetual check and white
threatens queen h5 with a lot of extra
material so assuming that black knows d5
which i think a lot of people will you
play bishop takes d5 and if knight takes
d5 you have to remember to take the
right piece and the right piece here is
the bishop on c5 this force is an end
game or white is simply a pawn up and in
the main line you don't play knight
takes f7 nope you play bishop takes f7
drop the bishop back to c4
you're threatening to play c3 you want
to castle and if black plays b5 you talk
your bishop away on d3 a couple of
important things here
uh generally if blackface h6 you're not
afraid of the pin and the reason you're
not afraid of it is because you're going
to go knight bd2 you can even castle in
this position and then drop the bishop
back to e2 so looks scary but totally
isn't if black plays your cafe you get
back to f3 on your own volition and
again knight takes f3 you play g takes
f3 do not be afraid of this pawn
structure it's actually very solid and
now you have the g file
at your disposal for the rook
so that's also good
and uh if bishop g4 then remember to
always meet that with f3 followed
followed by c3 and i think that
essentially covers all of black's
alternatives i
made
very sure to be as comprehensive as
possible um and let me see how long this
has gone for this has gone on for 25
minutes which is exactly the length that
i was targeting for an opening video um
so i you know i really hope that you've
enjoyed it
um
and and i hope that you know you
understand that this is this is for
serious players who who want to hunker
down and learn really learn how to face
these openings and that's the point i
want to make as i close this video which
is that a lot of my opening videos are
they're not going to be five minute
gimmicks they're going to be 20 25
minute uh long explanations which you
sort of have to study pretty seriously
but if you're willing to put in this
small time investment if you've sat
through until the end of the video first
of all thank you very much uh i hope
you've enjoyed it and second of all i
think that you will see
uh that you reap a lot of rewards
disproportionate rewards just by
spending half an hour of your time
studying all of these very very
important
lines so i hope you've enjoyed the
traxxar my opening videos will get
better i promise
and uh please feel free to leave
feedback and requests very important
leave opening requests in the comments
below thank you so much hope you've
enjoyed and goodbye
[Music]